we are going to begin in ukraine with
another major city under russian fire as
the capital of keefe reeled from more
bombing more shelling black smoke rose
over the previously untouched city of
levive after a strike there on what's
said to be a facility that repairs
military aircraft leve largest city in
the western part of ukraine about 40
miles from the polish border and nato
territory charlie dagetta is in key for
us charlie this is a shift in direction
for sure good morning to you
good morning to you yes the bombings in
levite the indiscriminate shelling on
the outskirts of the city here is now
spreading terror in the capital missiles
and artillery been landing here on a
daily basis sometimes several times a
day as russian forces intensify attacks
here and across the country
aftermath of the latest missile to slam
into a residential neighborhood here
this morning there's no telling when or
where the next rocket or rockets will
strike
parki the second largest city engulfed
in flames
and under constant bombardment
and in the besieged city of chernyhev an
american teacher among dozens of
ukrainian civilians killed 68 year old
jimmy hill who had stayed in ukraine to
look after his partner irina suffering
from ms
from pittsburgh katya hill recalled the
last time she spoke with her brother
i could hear bombs in the background
he
was going out on a daily basis searching
for food
the hospital lost it electricity the
hospital lost gas
there was no heat my brother was a
peacemaker
and he was a giver and
he just felt everybody in the world
should love each other
a man weeps over the body of his dead
mother in the capital killed after
fragments of a downed missile rain down
on this neighborhood this is what it
looks like when a missile misses
people pick up the pieces patiently
lining up for plastic sheeting
protection against the cold if not
searing shrapnel
these are some of the fragments of the
missile that the ukrainian military said
it intercepted as it flew overhead and
it caused incredible destruction at this
building and surrounding buildings you
can see why people are so worried about
what may come
even though this neighborhood is in the
firing line
even as gala varus chat plucks jagged
shards of glass from her window she
tells us he's not going anywhere
it's very cold
it's okay we won't freeze she says love
warms us up do you have a message for
america
peace in ukraine no more war and that
pooping comes to his senses
and we have an update on that bomb
theater in mario poll where there are
fears of like a thousand people taking
shelter this morning ukrainian officials
say around 130 people have been rescued
so far
vlad
charlie dagetta and keep charlie the
ukrainian spirit continues to inspire
everyone thank you very much we
appreciate it